اهلا بكم منبج هي الهدف التالي لعمليه درع
الفرات بعد اكمال سيطره القوات المشاركه
فيها على مدينه الباب وعيد س من ادلاء
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان بهذا
التصريح تقدمت المعارضه السوريه المسلحه
الى بلده جبله الحمراء جنوب شرق مدينه
الباب بريف حلب الشرقي بعد معارك مع
الوحدات الكرديه كما تقدم الجيش السوري
الحر بدعم تركي الى قريتي الكريد وام
حميره شرق الباب ايضا بعد معاركه مع تنظيم
الدوله تطورات ميدانيه تصاعد نذر المواجهه
وخلط الاوراق السياسيه في منطقه اطرافها
متضاربه المصالح والاهداف وهي الوحدات
الكرديه قوات النظام السوري وفصائل درع
الفرات المدعومه تركيا تقرير مريم
ابيش الباب السوريه هل ستبقى مفاتيحها بيد
قوات درع الفرات الجيش الحر المدعوم من
تركيا يريد الوصول الى الرقه لكن الطرق
اليها وعره سياسيا وعسكريا تتداخل فيها
حسابات معقد وصفقات غير معلنه بين النظام
ووحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه والنظام و ظم
الدوله وفق بعض المصادر ارياف حلب حاليا
ساحه معارك ربما يراد منها رسم خريطه
جديده وفرض امر واقع يطمح اليه كل طرف
متسارع عيون قوات درع الفرات الان على
منبج مدينه تسيطر عليها وحدات حمايه الشعب
الكرديه وتريد منها انقره ان تنسحب الى
شرق نهر
الفرات حققنا الكثير من التقدم في جرابلس
والراعي وذاب والباب في اطار عمليه درع
الفرات
المرحله المقبله هي منبج التي يتوجب ان
يسيطر عليها سكانها المحليون كفاحنا موجه
ضد تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه لا نسعى للبقاء
في سوريا اصحاب البلاد اولى بها لكننا لن
نسبح بان تبقى هذه الاماكن مصدر تهديد
لنا التهديد الاول لتركيا كان وسيبقى قيام
دوله كرديه على حدودها لذلك الا تريد ان
ينفرد الاكراد بمعركه القضاء على التنظيم
في الرقه الحرب بدات من الان بين من يسيطر
على ماذا بعد استعاده المناطق من مسلحي
التنظيم الاقتتال على الطرق المؤديه الى
الرقه لن ينتهي سريعا ووصول قوات درع
الفرات اليها لن يكون يسيرا ولا قريبا
لاكثر من سبب وفق الخريطه الراهنه للمنطقه
والقابله للتغيير كل الطرق مسدوده في وجه
الجيش الحر فبعد سيطرته على مدينه الباب
الاستراتيجيه بدا النظام السوري بدعم من
الميليشيات الاجنبيه في التقدم تمكن من
السيطره على بلده تادف وقرى جب السلطان
وزرياب الخفي وبالتالي حقق النظام اتصالا
جغرافيا مع مناطق سيطره القوات الكرديه في
محيط مدينه منبج ومعظم ريفها وعليه لا
يوجد حاليا خط تماس مباشر بين الجيش الحر
وتنظيم الدوله لاخيار امام قوات درع
الفرات سوى السيطره على منبج وانتزاعها من
القوات الكرديه تقدر خطوط اباك معها
بمسافه 40 كيلومترا ورهان انقره على
موافقه امريكيه لمشاركتها في استعاده
الرقه ليس سك ضمان بوقف المخططات الكرديه
امام درع الفرات معارك قد تكون اشرس من
الباب والذهاب الى منبج في الطريق الى
الرقه قد يفتح عليها ابواب
جهنم وقش الموضوع مع من انقره جاهد طوز
الباحث والمحلل السياسي التركي ومن باريس
عبد الناصر العيد المحلل العسكري
والاستراتيجي السوري سيد العيد ابدا معك
كيف ترى خارطه الصراع على الحدود التركيه
استنادا الى المعطيات الجديده التي
امامنا يعني
بتصور بده تشهد مرحله
ركود لن يكون بامكان درع الفرات ويعني من
خلفها الجيش
التركي ان يعني يدخل في ممر بين عدوين هم
يعني الوحدات الكرديه شمالا والنظام جنوبا
ويخترق الحاجز اللي صنعوه امامهم ليواجه
عدو ثالث هو تنظيم الدوله يعني بالتاكيد
هذه المعادله غير منطقيه وغير غير معقوله
الجيش الحر لديه بالتاكيد مصلحه بان يستمر
شرقا خاصه انه معظم يعني افراد او نسبه
كبيره من مقاتلي
ال درع الفرات هم من ابناء دير الزور
والرقه الطامحين للوصول لمناطقهم وتحريرها
من تنظيم داعش لكن بما اقامه النظام السد
اللي اللي اوجدوا امامهم اصبح يعني
طموحاتهم بالتوغل اكثر معلومه الاتراك
يعني بالتاكيد ايضا ليس لديهم مصلحه
بانه يطارد تنظيم داعش اكثر من هذا و
ويخترقوا مناطق سيطره على شمالهم للاكراد
اللي تابعين للامريكان وعلى ال على جنوبا
النظام السوري وال الميليشيات الايرانيه
اللي تابعه لروسيا يعني مش من مصلحه تركيا
الان تصطدم مع القوتين العظمتين من شان
تاخذ ممر لتروح تحارب داعش اللي هو بعد
بعد الباب لم يعد يمثل تهديدا حيويا يعني
كبيرا ل للامن التركي اعتقد انها ستلتفت
باتجاهات اخرى لكن موضوع منبج ايضا يعني
يبدو شب من المحظورات لانه حتى الان
الامريكان لا يريدون ان ان يعني بالفعل
يعني يدفعوا الوحدات الكرديه الى الانسحاب
شرق الفرات اي ربما ينتظرون يعني تطورات
معينه او اي تبلور خطه معينه لدى الروس
ولديهم حتى يفرطوا بهذه الورقه لذلك على
الاغلب الاتراك يجب عليهم ان ينتظروا في
الفتره القادمه وان يمكنوا اماكن سيطرتهم
ومواقعهم في ايه جرابلس و المنطقه من
جرابلس الى الباب وانتظار ال الخصمين
الرئيسيين الان على الساحه السوريه اللي
هم
الروس
والامريكان لحتى احدهما يعني يعرض عليه
عرضا ما يتقدم اما ان يتقدم
بعرض الخاصه طوز سمعت عبد الناصر العيد
يقول يعني ان هذا مكلف جدا بالنسبه لتركيا
بينما تصريحات الرئيس اردوغان تضع منبج
هدفا هل الهجوم على منبج هو خيار
استراتيجي رجعت عنه بالنسبه لاداره الرئيس
اردوغان
نعم في الحقيقه كما تعرفون تركيا عندما
بدات هذه عمليه وضحت بشكل واضح قالت ان
لدينا امامنا ثلاثه اهداف لبد هذه
العمليات ولم تبقى اي خيار امام تركيا الا
بدء هذه عمليه الاسباب اول اللي هو سبب ان
لم هذه مليشيات او منظمات ارهابيه التي
كانت موجوده قر الحدود التركيه وقامت
بكثير من العمليات الارهابيه بالداخل
تركيا اصبحت هد اصبحت تهديدا كبيرا على
امن القومي تركي ولذلك السبب اول هذا
السبب سبب ثاني كما تعرفون منذ بدء اندلاع
او انتقال ثورات عربيه الى سوريا تركيا
دائما تقول لابد انشاء منطقه
امنه لسوريين النقطه الثالثه تركيا ترى
بشكل واضح ونحن اليوم نفهم بشكل واضح
وندرك بشكل الواضح ان هناك ديناميكيات
تريد تحويل او تغيير ديموغرافيه في في في
المنطقه ولذلك تركيا لا تريد ذلك ولا تريد
ان تسمح لذلك الان ايضا هذه عمليه تتضمن
ثلاثه مراحل المرحله الاولى والمرحله
الثانيه نجح تم النجح وانجاز او تحقيق
الاول هو تحرير مدينه جرابلس وتركيا قوات
او جيش تركيا ترك مدينه جرابلس الى جيش
الحر واليوم
والان نجح الجيش التركي و والجيش الحر في
سوريا نجاح في مكافحه ارهاب في مدينه باب
وتركيا الجيش التركي سيترك هذه المدينه
الى الجيش الحر هناكله موم النقطه الثالثه
يعني مرحله المرحله الث المرحله الثالثه
هي سالت ه هل هو خيار استراتيجي لا رجعت
عنه السيد العيد يقول لك ان الدخول بين
خصمين لمواجهه خصم خصم ثالث هو يكلف كثيرا
و خاسر خاسر بالنتيجه هل هو سؤالي محدد هل
هو خيار استراتيجي رجعت عنه بعد حديث
الرئيس اردوغان
هنا هذه هذه خيار هذه نقطه استراتيجيه
وعمليه استراتيجيه ليس هناك خيار امام
صناع القرار التركيا الا انسحاب قوات او
مليشات كرديه من مدينه مبش لان تركيا لن
تشعر ابدا بامانه الا انسحاب هذه
المليشيات من من مدينه مبش هناك نقطه مهمه
لابد ان نتطرق اليها باختصار هي هي هي
تركيا الان لا تنتظر لاي دوله لا تنتظر من
اي دوله ان تبقى باي عمليه او تبقى باي
مشروع او تقوم باي مشروع بعد ذلك تركيا
تتضمن او تلحق بهذا بهذه الدوله سواء كان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه سواء كان
روسيا الان تركيا امام خطوه واستراتيجيه
واحده تطهير هذه مناطق من هذه منظمات
ارهابيه وليست هناك اي خيار للتراجع من
هذه الا انسحاب او الا تحرير مدينه جرابلس
وتم ذلك مدينه باب تم ذلك والان اتى الدور
ل مدينه مبش وهذه خطوه
ستبدا وبدات حاليا وستستمر في ذلك اما
عندما نتحدث هل ستستمر الى الرقه هذا هذا
الموضوع لابد ان اتحدث بشكل اخر لان هذا
الموضوع ليس لا تتعلق ب تركيا فقط بل هذه
مشكله كبيره للعالميه ولا بد ان تكون هناك
دول عالميه كلها ان تاخذ دوره في هذه
النقطه تركيا لوحدها لن تتدخل الى هذا
المو الموقف الامريكي والتركي من هذه
النقاط عبد الناصر العايد تحدثت عن
ستاتيكو او جمود في في في هذه المنطقه هل
يمكن لسيناريو في ظل هذا الجمود هل يمكن
لسيناريو ربط المناطق نتحدث من عين العرب
كوباني وصولا الى منبج مرورا بدف وعفرين
اي منطقه كرديه خالصه او كنتون كردي هل هل
ممكن لهذا السيناريو ان يجد موطئ قدم له
الان في ظل هذا
الجمود نعم يعني عن طريق المناطق اللي
يسيطر عليها النظام ونحن كنا سمعنا
التصريحات اللي يعني وال بعض الاخبار عن
التقاء قوات النظام بقصد وتصريحات قائد
قسد بانه يعني نحن م لنا يعني مالنا تابع
للنظام لكن
العلاقات التجاريه وغيرها لا بد انه تحدث
وما الى ذلك يعني في بدايات لعمليه
التعاون قد تتطور لانه يعني جعل هذه جعل
يعني ممر على شكل قو بمدينه حلب من
المتحدث باسم قوات سوريه الديمقراطيه ولكن
نحن نذكر سيد العابد سيد العيد نذكر
تصريحات
الجعفري ممثل النظام الان في جنيف عندما
قال عندما تم الحديث عن كنتون او منطقه
سيطره كرديه قال اليكم بحبات البنادول هل
يمكن للنظام السوري ان يهرب الى الامام
ويسلم هذه المناطق الى كنتون
كردي يعني هو لا لا يريد لن يسلمها هم
يعني موجودين في عفرين وموجودين في منبج
كل ما يمكن ان يقدمه لهم هو صله وصل يعني
طريق مرور عبور بين هذين الكونين مبدئيا
تصريحات الجعفري جاءت في بفتره يعني كان
فيها غزل مع تركيا كانت بوقت الاستداره
التركيه تغير الموقف التركي وكانوا
بيعتقدوا النظام وروسيا انه الموقف التركي
انقلب كليا
ف والروس والنظام ضمنوا للاتراك انه خلص
ما عاد في كانتون كردي وهي الفزاعه اللي
هم صنعوها النظام هو بالاصل هو صنعها من
اجل تهديد تركيا عندما ادت الثوره السوريه
انه خلاص بنقضى عليها ونتذكر وقتها ايضا
حتى طائرات النظام قصفت القوات الكرديه في
في القامشلي وحلقت حينها طائرات امريكيه
وانذرهم انذار اخير بانه اي تحليق فوق
القوات الكرديه منذ الان فصاعدا سيواجه ب
باسقاط الطائرات هذه الفتره كانت وانقضت
يعني انتهت الان يعني لن يقول هذا لانه
بدا انه الموقف التركي بدا يتغير مع
العوده الامريكيه للمنطقه لذلك من الوارد
جدا انه النظام يرجع يقوي ه الجيوب
الكرديه وينعشها
ويدعمها لحتى ترجع تشك التهديد
لتركيا الاتراك الان يعني كما قال ضيفك
يعني اذا كان فعلا لديهم قرار ب مهاجمه
منبج والاستيلاء عليها بعتقد انه يغامروا
بمواجهه يعني كبيره على الاغلب يعني مع
يعني ستصطدم بالامريكان الامريكان حتى
الان يحتاجون للاكراد في مواجهاتهم بشرق
الفرات بالرقه والطبقه وغيرها وقدروا به
المرحله الاقابل جه طوز انت ذكرت يعني
امور تحتاج الى تفاهمات دوليه اطرافها
امريكا روسيا وتركيا ايضا تركيا الان هي
دوله راعيه لمفاوضات استنه لتثبيت وقف
اطلاق النار دخول الان تركيا وفتح جبهه
جديده سواء مع النظام في منطقه تادف
والباب او مع قوات حمايه الشعب الكرديه في
منطقه منبج الا يؤثر على علاقاتها
السياسيه مع روسيا والمتوتر اصلا مع
ايران لا شك في اونه الاخيره نشاهد كثير
من من الزيارات المتبادله بين المستوى
العسكري والمستوى سياسي
بين تركيا والولايات المتحده امريكيه وتم
نقاش حول هذه المواضيع كلها بالنسبه الى
ولايات علاقات الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وتركيا هناك مشكله اساسي في هذا هذا
الموضوع حقيقه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تريد ان تبدا عمليه ب مع ميليشيات كرده
بوجود ميليشيات كرديه وتركيا ترفض ذلك
اطلاقا ولن تسمح لذلك وابلغ الى صناع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بهذا بشكل
واضح ولذلك تركيا الان طبعا الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اتى كثير من التصريحات
ان نحن نريد ان ان ان تركيا تعطينا
النموذج ان تركيا تستطيع او نستطيع مع
تركيا مكاف الارهاب في في في في سوريا في
في رقه خاصه وتركيا هناك نموذجين مهمين
خاصه نموذج جرابلس ونموذج باب تعطينا
اشارات او دلائل قويه ان تركيا قادره على
مكافحه الارهاب هناك وتركيا لا تريد ان
تكون هناك اي مناظ ارهابيه في هذه العمليه
لان العمليه ارهاب ضد او مكافحه ارهاب مع
المنظمه الارهاب لا يفيد اي شيء ولذلك
تركيا مصير على هذه النقطه اما بالنسبه
الى الى علاقات تركيا وروسيا طبعا الملف
الذي الملف الذي تركيا وروسيا تشتغل عليه
هي مصيره سياسيه وفي اجتماع اسانه واعتقد
تركيا وروسيا اكثر ستهتم بهذه النقطه
والنقطه اخرى اخيرا تركيا للا تسمح لاي
ميليشيات ايضا موالي
للايراني في داخل سوريا ممكن نشاهد بعض
المناوشات بين تر بين الجيش تركي او بين
جيش حر وجيش بشار الاسد ولكن من خلال
روسيا ستكون هناك ضغط على جيش الاسد حتى
لا تتقدم في في هذه المناطق واعتقد في هذه
النقطه هناك تفاهم بين الولايات المتحده
امريكيه بين روسيا وايضا بين تركيا في هذا
الموضوع وايام المقبله سنشاهد نتائج هذه
الاشياء او نتائج هذا التفاهم جاهد طوز
الباحث والمحلل السياسي في انقره شكرا لك
واشكر من باريس عبد الناصر العيد المحلل
العسكري والاستراتيجي السوري m